a fiery moment at the White House a day
press-secretary Sarah Sanders fighting
back against the media as far as I know
I'm the first press secretary in the
history of the United States that's
required Secret Service protection we'll
have more on that in a moment but first
president Trump is back on the campaign
trail tonight in Pennsylvania as a
familiar foe emerges to counter his
message in the midterms former President
Obama announcing he's planning to stump
for Democrats this fall if it's anything
like 2016 the battle between the two
heavyweights is sure to get nasty
watch thousands of Americans would be
alive today if not for the open border
policies of Barack Obama
they say Donald lacks the foreign policy
experience to be President but in
fairness he has spent years meeting with
leaders from around the world miss
Sweden miss Argentina misses her by John
President Obama he is the founder of
Isis he's the founder of Isis the Donald
is not really a plans guy he's not
really a facts guy either this is a
president who doesn't have a clue the
guy says stuff that no buddy would find
tolerable if they were applying for a
job that's 7-eleven meanwhile Obama is
endorsing dozens of Democrats and making
headlines for who he's backing and who
he's not he's throwing his weight behind
a congressional candidate in New Mexico
who wants to abolish ice and he's
snubbing self-proclaimed socialist
Alexandria of kasnia Cortes jesse is
this the election we deserve another
rematch between Donald Trump and Bravo
I'll have to see those two debate
wouldn't you that because that would be
one bath right there I mean I think the
country already rejected a third Obama
term when they rejected Hillary Clinton
and Obama doesn't do very well when he's
not on the ballot remember he just got
shellacked during both midterms during
his presidency and him getting back on
the trail activates the Democratic base
but it also reactivates the Republican
base so they're going to be pretty fired
up when they see
him out there stumping I don't believe
the country wants to look backwards I
think the country wants to look forwards
what we saw during the Obama years were
a terrible economy racial riots a lot of
consternation in the public there wasn't
a lot of good things that were happening
health care chaos etc etc now we're in a
new environment and for Obama to get
back out there
I don't think helps I think actually
hurts the Democrats and give us a
president Trump a big punching bag
that's a very big target Trump does well
when he has something to punch against
Juan do you think that Democrats though
will benefit from President Obama being
out on the campaign trail for them
tremendously would you like to expand
60% 60% plus approval rating high energy
and we know about his capacity as an
orator or just as a campaigner it's very
strong and then when you think about it
for example on these endorsements he has
been strategic he endorses candidates
where his endorsement will benefit them
he doesn't endorse for example Joe
Manchin in West Virginia which is a
strong Trump state he doesn't endorse
Joe Donnelly in Indiana so he's picking
his spots and I think he's doing so very
well and also don't forget money counts
Dana in politics and he's very good at
raising money and he's going to have his
supporters and people who think he's
still the cat's meow come out when you
talk about energy or something like
jesse was saying health care and so
forth health care cath health care Cass
is what we got now where you see the
Trump administration trying to provide
these inadequate you know subpar plan
let's not argue about just look at what
the American people are saying trust the
American people once they're saying Dave
Obama again still face here's what I
would say to you they voted in 2010 in
reaction to Obamacare remember it was
being belittled and demonized at the
time by opponents but boy the Americans
people's attitudes have shift it's a
fortune I mean that's the problem like
I think Republicans you're talking about
Obamacare single-payer no no I think
there's an argument now about
single-payer oh that's even worse okay I
mean I agree with you I think President
Obama does a great job as a campaigner I
think that's his strength but the
problem is he has to campaign now
against success he has to campaign
against policies that have worked he has
to look people in the eye whose taxes
have gone down who have less regulation
has they've been able to expand their
businesses who have more freedom where
you have an administration who's saying
we don't like Obamacare we want to find
out ways to give you opportunities to
get the health insurance you decide is
right for you and he has to say oh that
that GDP growth and that decreased taxes
oh that's all bad so what is he gonna do
he's gonna do what he does best and he's
gonna pivot to Republicans and Trump
hate immigrants which is alive
Republicans in Trump hey you know all
this this nonsense that he always does
it makes a good point Gregg about is
President Obama's chedi chaya she makes
a good point the President Obama really
go out there and talk down the economy I
mean it's not a good idea to talk down
prosperity yes and we can tell by that
montage that we showed that everything
Obama said was scripted everything Trump
said was off the cuff so that's in
Trump's favor look I feel bad for the
Democrats it's like they dropped their
iPhone in the toilet so now they went to
the junk drawer to get the flip phone
that's Obama he's the flip phone they
had to get something out of storage to
save their party more like iPhone 4 and
Hillary Clement stick don't try to screw
with my analogies Dana that's all I've
got going and how you know what this is
this is really about time off the media
in and the comedian's have been working
really hard and they needed a much much
deserved nap Obama's back in town they
know he's off limits you can't make
jokes about Obama right no comedians
gonna make it each oakes the media's
don't have to meet it a sign of the
chase Obama around they don't have to
hound him so basically what Obama is
it's a break for the comedians and it's
a break for the media because they can't
joke about him I don't blame Pope
for coming out of hiding he's basically
yesterday's special on the restaurant
blackboard that Trump came out in the
morning and erased Clinton out there
absolutely I mean Obama is much better
than crooked Hillary and it sets up a
big contrast as opposed to a referendum
if there's no big punching bag or
villain for Trump to run against it's a
little more difficult but when you have
Barack Obama out there the media is
going to hoist those two guys back up
into the center and make it a cage match
and as in terms of the endorsements from
what we're hearing he only made those
endorsements because his former staff
members were working for those
candidates I don't know how strategic it
was and I understand why he didn't
endorse Cortes because if he had done
that that would have created a huge huge
problem with the Democratic Party
because that would have been a major
blow to the centrist wing of the party
and they don't need that kind of fight
right now going into the midterm maybe
he also watched some of our interviews
because I wasn't no seriously I mean she
when she's posed with a question as to
she has these lofty ideas about oh let's
give Medicare for all when you ask her
how she's gonna pay for it her answer is
absurd when you ask her about the
israeli-palestinian crisis she has no
idea what she's talking about so
President Obama I agree I disagree with
him on a lot of things he's not a stupid
guy I think he's he's probably worried
about that you have politically smart
non endorsement curious how you guys
pose this you say oh is Obama going to
run against the economy Obama is the guy
that saved the Anapa and not only did he
save the American economy at the moment
Jesse it's Republicans who are not oh
you kidding you must have forgotten we
had a Great Recession in Obama's
responsible for everything good
Trump responsible for everything bad I
don't even agree with the reverse come
on I'm not so I'm just saying go look at
the facts if you want to go look at the
Econo economic arrows and directions
coming out of o8 when Obama was elected
first term and what the United States
has done since you'd say hmm I think I
did pretty well
session since y2k because guess what it
was a terrible it was the worst
recoveries really good very on the
economy this here's the news going into
the midterms yes Republicans had planned
to run on the Trump tax cuts everybody
is still encouraging Republicans to say
hey talk about the economy folks forget
the demonizing of immigrants forget
going after the NFL players and playing
all those kind of the Trump rally was
talking up the tax cuts pretty big guess
what it's not working Jesse the American
people say they haven't seen their wages
increased ways there were these American
people that you be talking on the Acela
train no you know what you should go
look at some poll I looking for spouting
your no no no no the funny thing is you
pick and choose poll polls and over
loved ones like the ones about Russian
collusion in which they say they're
they're not interested at all in the in
the babble that you spouts oh yeah let
me say they are interested in whether or
not this president was having some
collusion that's where optimism has
never been hired you optimism has never
been higher and that's not in my notes
let me just say why did why did you see
so many Trump officials come out today
and say we are actively engaged in
trying to stop the Russians from
interfering in the 2016 race it's
because Gregg those people understand
the American people do care about the
idea of the employee shows that it's not
that that issue ranked less and any
other issue he wants to talk about
Russia because he can't talk about the
economy no honestly do people have more
jobs right now are the unemployment
numbers down
ok the unemployed people have more money
in their pockets to put food on their
people everyday that I couldn't get a
job five years ago and now I can't no
that's what I'm talking about with the
economy if he goes out and he talks
about the shrinking unemployment numbers
if he goes out and he talks about
providing more opportunities for people
with health care or whatever it may be
he goes out and talks about low taxes
and people are feeling those impacts in
their pocketbook every day that's all
that matters nobody's going to be
talking about collusion with Russia
which by the way there's been no
proof of if they can't put food on the
table for their kids well I would agree
but I'm just telling you right now it I
mean you don't even have to just say Oh
Democrats think this look at what
Republican strategists are saying they
would like to get on the economy they
like the tump pump that up but what they
see is it's not working with the voters
and up is talking about of course as we
say leave you with one last headline not
from a fake news article from CNBC CNBC
says quote worker compensation at
highest level since 2008 yeah that's not
Fox News NBC it's they know the data
correct and it's what you see is it's a
very slow stagnant what you're saying
it's just still it's super hard to try
to make that argument it is intelligence
I might try to do it but I think that I
don't think they're running against the
economy I think they're just saying be
realistic and most Americans the reason
people are frustrated with the economy
is they feel they're not getting a fair
share generalizations that are not
proven what were you gonna say I want to
hear what you were about to say that he
cut you off just say it's not that it's
hard to make that the argument that he's
trying to make is very hard to make when
the headlines across all the papers are
that things are better
optimism feels but it's like a feeling
so President Trump is going they're
gonna have a battle weight and you know
what actually we don't even know exactly
what is going to happen in October
that's always a month when there's big
news on all sorts of things you could
have a really good GDP number and a jobs
number of that month that could be the
talk of the town there could be some
disaster there could be you never know
what's going to happen but I think the
president is pretty well positioned
going into this debate that I'll give
myself the last word